right now we have John's on deck he's
from he's a president of ATT Missouri
and they are a sponsor of the st. Louis
chess club good man yes we always love
to have friends here at the club and
John son is a Sondag who is the
president of AT&T Missouri is such a
friend first of all welcome to the show
it's always a pleasure thanks for having
me tell us about AT&T Missouri's
involvement in chess initiatives we know
you support college prep initiatives why
chess well a couple things first of all
education is our number one
philanthropic objective and you know and
focusing on the high school dropout
problem and I think when we look at
chess one its it's something that can be
brought into you know inner-city schools
it's not a very expensive sport to start
off with with with what you have but I
think that the the critical thinking the
strategic thinking the discipline you
have to have to play the game I think
that that goes hand-in-hand with with I
think focusing kids on how to how to
stay at attentive how to focus on
something like this and I think it
bleeds out over into their schoolwork
absolutely something I hundred percent
support and believe in what are the
initiatives do you do you support as a
company so you know we as I mentioned
Phil we support a lot but education is
the primary focus so we will work not
only in the high school dropout issue
that I mentioned but also on promoting
stem curriculum so we work with
organizations like let's say the Boy
Scouts focusing with them on how to
refocus the scouting program so that's
more on some of the science related
merit badges so we'll get involved them
to try to integrate those programs along
with camping but really any organization
that works with schools Big Brothers Big
Sisters here a lot of things that when
they focus on an education related
program and how to bring that especially
to inner-city or disadvantaged schools
those are things we'd like to invest in
we think in the long term it'll help the
education level will help the kids and
ultimately it betters the communities
where we serve right so let me ask you a
chess player I am NOT a very good one
but I enjoy playing and
I find that as I've gotten older my
patience level and wanting to really sit
there in focus starts to wane but I
think it's great I you know I play with
my kids or they're in their 20s now and
we played some say array were small they
still enjoy doing that and I love
getting out and having a good game who's
the boss of the family in chess I'd have
to say probably my son who 27 year old
he's a engineer and he's grown up he's
he's got the smarts and the maneuvers
and he's got the patience now sometimes
I don't I want to try to try to go for
the win quickly and you know that's not
the smart way to do it have you ever
played Rex I have not played Rex and
we've talked about that but I I think
Rex could probably beat me but I'd be
willing to take them on Rex will make an
illegal move and you'll win the game
there you go I can count on a knack to
excel counts the same well thanks so
much for joining us we appreciate all
the initiatives that your company does
we appreciate all the friendship that
you provide and support for the kids in
chess great it says it's a great
endeavor and we're happy to support it
John Sonntag
president of AT&T Missouri one of the
many companies there supporting chess
initiatives here in st. Louis